Apple's new 14-inch M2 Pro MacBook Pro
is finally here at the same two thousand
dollar price which is great but the
problem is that the M2 MacBook Air is on
sale right now for only 1100 on Amazon
about half the price with taxes included
so is it really worth spending the extra
cash well in this video I'm gonna
compare everything from an honest real
world perspective and keep it short and
sweet but before I do that I do want to
mention that we're doing a giveaway of a
new M2 Pro MacBook Pro and new Mac Mini
and all you have to do to enter is
subscribe below enable notifications and
comment down below to enter and you can
actually get more entries by commenting
on all of our Mac videos this month and
we're gonna announce the winner on
February 1st so don't miss out on that
video in terms of design they look
extremely similar with the 14 inch pro
just looking like a chunkier version of
the air but the difference can really be
felt when holding them in your hands the
air just feels so thin and light that
it's almost unreal now because of the 14
inch Pro's thicker design The Edge can
dig into your wrist a bit when typing
and even though they have the same magic
keyboard the air does seem to have a bit
more feedback when typing and the
trackpad actually feels a bit more
clicky the nice thing about the new M2
Pro MacBook Pro is that you do get the
updated Bluetooth 5.3 and Wi-Fi 6E specs
while you're limited to Bluetooth 5.0
and Wi-Fi 6 so it doesn't take advantage
of the new 6 gigahertz band now as far
as the speakers the ones on the 14-inch
Pro have actually changed compared to
the previous model being a bit less
sharp in terms of the highs with lower
volume but they're still much better
than the ones in the MacBook Air just
hear it for yourself
[Music]
the difference is shocking especially in
terms of the volume and bass so if you
really care about speakers the 14 inch
pro is a lot better now in terms of the
actual ports the 14 inch comes with an
extra Thunderbolt Port an SD card slot
which is extremely useful in my opinion
and of course an HDMI port which has now
been upgraded to the 2.1 spec so it
supports 8K displays at 60 hertz and 4K
displays at 240 hertz which is insane
now on the air you simply just get the
two Thunderbolt ports on top of the max8
which both of them share and that is it
which is a bummer but you can also get a
cheap adapter if you want like this one
on Amazon now a big deal to me is the
pro motion display on the 14 inch model
which goes up to 120 hertz compared to
standard 60 so it is super super smooth
and it's also mini LED going up to 1600
nits of brightness much brighter than
the M2 now as for the webcams the new Mt
pro model now comes with an ISP upgrade
or image signal processor matching the
M2 Chip so they look a lot more similar
than before this is the M2 MacBook airs
webcam as you can see it's pretty good
it does have the new ISP from the a15
chip just like on the M2 Pro so let's go
ahead and switch over and now here we
have the M2 Pro MacBook Pro and here it
actually looks like the white balance is
a little bit more warm on this one
compared to the other one and let me
know how the actual microphones sound on
this guy compared to the MacBook Air
down in the comment section below now is
a really good time to talk about fan
noise or lack thereof if you're someone
who constantly does Zoom meetings your
current laptop might get annoying
because after a while the fan will spin
up to keep it cool as it's processing
the video feed which was a huge issue
with the Intel MacBook Air and it also
impacted audio quality the M2 MacBook
Air is completely fanless so it's always
silent but you might be worried about
the 14 inch pro as it does have dual
fans but thankfully for most tasks the
fans are literally shut off thanks to
Apple silicon being very efficient and
since the heat pipes now pull a lot of
heat away from the processor now if you
are doing very tough tasks then they
will spin up but they still stay pretty
quiet now some people have mentioned
that the M2 air bottom case can get
really hot with extended loads and that
is true the 14 inch exhausts the heat
upwards through the hinge away from you
but the fanless M2 airs bottom case can
reach 47 degrees Celsius since the heat
is trapped there and up to 108 degrees
Celsius internally which is much hotter
than the 14 inch and if you're wondering
how this impacts performance without a
fan well inner detail testing we found
it can lose 17 of its performance after
about 10 minutes and that's just the CPU
alone with Graphics the performance loss
can be over 26 percent and if you're
loading up both of them it can be even
worse so if you're pushing your Mac hard
the pro is the way to go but if you need
to save cash or want the thin and light
design a thin laptop cooler can make a
surprising Difference by itself and if
you pair it with a 15 thermal pad it can
even outperform an M2 13-inch MacBook
Pro that has more powerful Graphics I'm
going to link the cooler and the full
video down in the description so what
about performance this is the real
reason why most people would buy the 14
inch pro instead of the air right and it
might be the biggest reason why you're
considering it well I want to challenge
you a little bit and have you take a
second and ask yourselves how much
performance do you really need first off
the two thousand dollar 14 inch MacBook
Pro is the double binned version meaning
that to get the full M2 Pro chip it
costs at least twenty three hundred
dollars and second even the base M2 air
already beats out even the previous best
16 inch Intel MacBook Pro and many tasks
and absolutely wiped the floor with the
Intel MacBook airs in the real world the
air has more than enough performance for
most people but I do have to add that we
are using a 512 gig SSD model of the air
because the base 256 gig model has a
slow SSD that will not only slow down
transfers but your whole machine if
you're multitasking and doing
productivity work and unfortunately the
new M2 Pro base 14 inch also has the
same SSD issue with half the amount of
chips than before but it won't be as big
of a deal because the SSD speed is still
still quite a bit faster than on the M2
air now as far as performance the M2 Pro
is slightly faster in terms of geekbench
5's single core test which will lead to
a very slight Improvement in terms of
web-based app performance and it's a lot
faster for the multi-core test which is
why most people doing a lot of
productivity work should choose that
instead especially if you're willing to
pay 300 extra for the chip upgrade now
for battery life they're rated at the
same 18 hours and that's because the M2
Pro chip now has four efficiency cores
just like the M2 in the MacBook Air so
battery life overall should be very
similar however if you push the machines
like crazy with a bunch of performance
tasks the 14-inch M2 Pro will end up
using more because the chip can use
quite a lot more power now when you do
need full performance for more than 10
minutes that's where the N2 Pro really
gets ahead being 60 faster than the them
to Air and almost two and a half times
faster in terms of Graphics because the
air ends up throttling down after just
four to five minutes so if you're doing
Graphics heavy tasks like gaming or
productivity tasks that rely on Graphics
this is where the 14 inch pro really
starts to stand out but let's be real
most of you wanted the air probably
won't be working with heavy workloads
but using it for web browsing some light
productivity and some normal creative
work here the differences aren't as big
but they're still there like for
exporting Raw photos so anyone who cares
about performance would benefit from the
14-inch M2 Pro especially for those who
are used to doing extended 100 workloads
especially for graphics and of course
you can't forget that the 14 inch comes
with a mini LED xdr display that is
capable of hitting 1600 nits instead of
500 on the empty MacBook Air and for
normal use you won't notice a difference
when you're just doing regular stuff but
when it comes time for HDR editing or
viewing the 14 inch gives you a much
better experience with really great
contrast and brightness that the M2 air
simply can't achieve as well as of
course the 120hz promotion for super
smooth scrolling which I don't notice as
much as I do on my phone and being able
to play games at above 60 FPS is also
great personally unless you know that
you want or need many of the benefits
the 14 inch provides I think the air is
a great machine and is much more
pleasant for taking on the go but if you
don't mind the size and you can afford
it you do get better bang for the buck
with the M2 Pro machine so hopefully you
enjoy this comparison and if you'd
rather just get a better deal on a
MacBook rather than the new ones use the
YouTube tagging feature below to check
out some great deals and click that
Circle above to subscribe Vibe for more
videos like this one definitely check
out some of our other video comparisons
that we've been doing recently and we
have a lot more testing to do with these
new 14-inch MacBook Pros as well as a 16
inch and the M2 Max chips so stay tuned
for that
[Music]